[Music]
please don't get involved
what is happening thickies welcome to
the shob show this isn't your
traditional show
a lot of you are going to be
disappointed because as i'm shooting
this right now it is friday afternoon
but you're watching this on monday and
you're expecting your normal shop show
unfortunately
but also fortunately for the first time
i'm missing the show that's right i am
missing the show and i apologize but
it's for a good reason
because as you're watching this i will
be in new york i'm in new york doing
press for my special that just dropped
the gringo poppy if you haven't seen it
you need to see it if you're a fan
if you like comedy go what it's actually
on the page that you're watching right
now my comedy special the gringo poppies
on this page i think scroll up or scroll
down you'll find it you can't miss it go
check it out it is 30 minutes of me
lighting up my latina family i think
it's good
uh and i'm i'm seeing all the love from
you guys you know the the special's only
been out a few days and uh it's been an
overwhelming response i can't thank you
guys enough
you know it's a risk for me to to better
myself and
and do it like this and you never know
what the right decision is but
i i think after the first day i knew
this was the right decision it doesn't
have anything to do with me it's all you
guys so the love and the support i can't
thank you enough
i am
so blessed man and i i love you i can't
tell you guys enough how much i
appreciate you and i love you guys so um
yeah go check out my special the gringo
poppy on think boy youtube right now and
you probably
can see it on one of these boxes you'll
find it but if you are sad that you're
not getting an episode this week i have
good news
i've done
7 000 other podcasts to promote my
special the gringo poppy so you can find
me on impulsive with logan paul that's
available you can see me on bert
kreischer the the the burt cast that's
available you can find me on joe rogan
jre on spotify that's available that's a
fun one it's a good one did i throw up
in the uber driving home yeah i did we
drank too much whiskey tiger thick
you can go get tiger thick matter of
fact thickboy.com it's available now
online that's cool uh if you so you
missed those three if you've heard them
like i need some more job well uh
since it's monday today i'll be shooting
christa stefano show i'll be shooting
flagrant 2 with andrew schultz and akash
i'll be shooting are you garbage with
the kevin the boys the comics in new
york and then on tuesday i will be at
bar
and i will be with garyvee michael
rappaport a lot more so there's a ton of
content out there i'm sick of talking
but in some weird world you're not sick
of hearing my voice
you can go listen to any of those
podcasts so i will see you guys next
monday
i'm sure i'll have a ton of stuff to
talk about in the fight world
and if you miss my voice you can go
listen to all those other podcasts i'm
on promoting my special the gringo poppy
so go watch it right now if you haven't
seen it again i love you guys thank you
so much i feel the love i feel the love
so uh i just want to say thank you and i
will see you guys next week appreciate
it